in the dogon village of comecon in mali
preparations are underway for rare event
the village dama Damas can be held only
after a good harvest and in this
environment that doesn't happen very
often the Dhamma is a mask festival that
honors deceased elders it is more than a
celebration the Dhamma is a door to
Dogon manhood to wear a mask and dance
at a Dhamma is what every boy lives for
without the Dhamma young men can feel
suspended between boyhood and manhood
this is the case for automated ogle o
Sai who is 29 but doesn't yet consider
himself a man she loved you do good
continent but if you're not initiated
you're not a whole man you're thought to
be a bit like a woman they'll come there
for them that's why the Dhamma is so
important to us
autumn a is from another dogon village
where his grandfather is the oldest man
in the village the revered keeper of the
masks it's his responsibility to
determine the timing of the Dhamma but
there's a conflict some years ago a
spirit told the village fortune-teller
that the next Dhamma would herald the
grandfather's
the last online optimized village was 20
years ago I knew I'd never ever hit a
job you guys oh don't worry about doing
our boy back in komak on the whirring
song of the bull-roarer announces that
the celebrations will soon begin
[Music]
meanwhile ultime decides to act he asks
the fortune teller to contact the spirit
that seems to a condemned him to eternal
childhood the old man is the village
shaman and the figure who predicts the
future with him is the pale Fox the
shaman draws patterns in the sand for
the divination the elusive pale Fox
emerges in the cool of the night looks
like he may have his answer
you know Medora bottom a the shaman says
we'll be part of a Dhamma with thousands
back in komak on the new day heralds the
start of the ceremony that ought to make
an only dream of how are you doing boy
nobody would believe you boy
every household offers millet to thank
spirits the old man of comecon beat the
dancing showing the youngsters how it's
done autumn a may have the fox's
blessing but he still has to persuade
his grandfather autumn a knows his quest
will benefit all the young men in his
village though he implores his
grandfather to initiate the dom
eventually the old man rillettes even
though it may seal his fate the dhamma
however will not be this year for
optimist village Sina pastor Donny
misses Utica even though the dom is not
this year
kid what does it will come I hope so I
will be allowed to dance I'm so happy
the other stuff this year autumn a
ground millet $4
next year it might be him behind the
mask